greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happening now is brought to
you by 23andme from today now took
December 25th the 23andme DNA kits are
on sale 23andme helps you understand
what your DNA can tell you about you and
your family's family's story it's named
for the 23 pairs of chromosomes that
make up your DNA
now the 23andme DNA kit is a perfect
gift everyone you love there's never
been a better way to give the gift of
genetic discovery to your parents your
siblings your friends you grow anybody
anybody in your Christmas list this is a
easy way it's the one gift that you can
buy the entire family that will be
unique for each loved one and I'll tell
you what it's good for like your friends
at work and whatnot what I'm going to do
is this from today to December 25th till
Christmas I'm gonna give you 30% off any
23andme kit order your DNA kit at
23andme dot-com slash church again
23andme comm slash Church and give me a
30% off that's the number 23andme dot
coms last Church again 23andme dot-com
slash church now she was here a couple
of weeks ago we had a great time I'm not
gonna tell you again why be genetically
and genetically [ __ ] unclean why must
your [ __ ] smell like [ __ ] ten
billy goats
why must you walk around with your ball
stinking you don't need that no more you
know why hello Toshi comm that's why the
leader in portable bidets across the
[ __ ] world as far as I'm concerned
I've had mine for three years with my
fat [ __ ] ass that still hasn't broken
it and they give you like a 60 and 90
day money-back guarantee you're not
gonna need it this thing is tremendous
you could get they start at $69 and you
get them with a hot or cold setting you
don't know what it's like for medium
lukewarm water to be in your air so
model mummy it's like a [ __ ] party
and I'm saying all these people wanna
artificial intelligence listen go [ __ ]
yourself get somebody
hot water in your [ __ ] that's
artificial intelligence do me a favor
forget a hello Turkey dot-com right now
you see anybody day you want press in
muffler muffler mu FF l ER and get 10%
off your this to makes a great Christmas
gift alright mule-kick this [ __ ]
what's the story check out what the [ __ ]
you been hmm I got you know witness
relocation plan up an old mo what's up
buddy you look great thank you good to
see you guys it's good to see you man it
was great to see you at her violently I
reached out yeah and I appreciate that I
know when you're a dad night out two
hours I yeah as always and you don't
really want to leave like ain't leaving
my wife and a lurch mmm you have other
family down here to help your wife out
not really you know we got her brother
and sister-in-law down the down here but
all my family's back at home also not a
lot but but you know my McKenzie she's
super mama she's amazing
she's no they have no choice yeah dad
look they really do I mean they just I
give my wife props
my wife is done at 8:30 hmm and I get it
there's some nights I feel a little
alienated but I got over that years ago
it's tough mmm it's tough I know you
know even when I sit with mercy three
four hours when I leave there like your
head spinning last Saturday I was on the
road I know I spoke to my wife my wife
left the house 9:30 in the morning
and she didn't get back till 6:30 oh she
went to three parties damn that's tough
wait watching you kids yell and get them
in the car while I'm around it's it's
tough when we go to those parties but I
enjoy mmm you enjoy it it's crazy
because I I used to think and I still do
think I want kids but whenever I see
parents with little kids like out and
I'm like that's I'm nowhere near ready
for that that's a different kind of
commitment
here's the thing that nobody's ever
ready that's always ever ready you don't
get a phone call that says hey
you're gonna have a kid February 8th
2019 nobody says that there so you know
you meet a girl you start date and you
get wrist a bird he's got a long you
talk like so you know she tells you
she's knocked up what he did they read a
handbook it was mean ed though we had do
you think about your father
exactly and you talk about his work
ethics and how you made it work and you
look at your life and you figure it the
[ __ ] out you know and then you have to
what it really did with me was it taught
me about time I knew about time years
ago but what you have a child you really
learn about time management
no no doubt cuz you you want to spend
most of you as much time as you can just
plan with them and it's just you can't
put it on somebody you know there's a
line and the Godfather when he smacks
the guy that's supposed to be Sinatra
and he says something stupid when I was
10 I already chose any man was to spend
time with their family is not really a
man and I thought about that you don't
know how many times I'm sitting at a
[ __ ] swim class and I'm thinking to
myself what the [ __ ] am I doing here I
could be writing a joke but in the
middle of that core thought you can't
come up with swimming and look over here
for like that visual type of support and
that's why you're there you know you
have to show up to those things you have
to be a part and it's tough for some
families we're living in a world right
now where [ __ ] some parents have three
jobs they have two yes there's a guy who
I do open mics with who's almost exactly
my age and has twin five-year-old girls
I'm like wow that is you know whatever
your dream is now you got to pay the
mortgage I'm a Houston Alexander mmm I'm
it usually where is he fighting now do
you know if he's still her I know I
actually don't know if he's still
fighting last night talk to him you
still fighting but uh
somewhere local I don't a minute he was
out of the braska so yeah he wasn't
around yeah and I remember that he
fought twice and he knocked some people
out and I didn't know how I felt the
bottom I didn't know if I was a fan you
know whatever I was just watching mm-hmm
but I saw one on one of them that he
raised his kids I guess I mean the wife
broke up or something and so he would
have to get up at 6:00 or 5 something
crazy train for an hour and then make
breakfast get the kids ready and he
drove her UPS truck which as we know is
no [ __ ] cushy job and then he would
get home feed the kids bathe them read
them books put them to bed and then he
would go to the gym at 10 o'clock at
night 9 o'clock at night for an hour and
a half or something train I gained a
whole new level of respect yeah yeah no
you haven't look at a guy and go wow it
looks like he's a trainer and he has I
think you know says he is a radio
personality so maybe he's he's not he's
retired now you know I mean think about
that life we think about you I remember
Josh wolf when Josh wolf it was a time
Josh wolf was raising three kids and
doing Connelly by himself his wife had
had problems and she had to go away for
a while and it was me and Jonathan that
would Josh wolves help with Josh social
Joshua will tell you that I watched his
kids and I watched his kids because I
couldn't let somebody do that all by eye
he did everything he cooked me the
dishes he did laundry he vacuumed
you know whenever you went over to Josh
Lowe's house he was [ __ ] working
you didn't just talk to him man-to-man
you know why you were talking to him he
was cooking or washing dishes or so
after a while you pick up vacuum and
help him out or whatever you know what
do you I mean what do you think about
someone I
well I was thinking about Derrick Lewis
who like said in the interviews for his
last fight that he's more he just he's
there to fight to like support his
family but he's not it's not as much of
an art like what do fighters look down
on people who aren't in it as like a
martial art like what is that it's it's
hard to say I mean you know there's so
many mouth-breathers in this world and
the fight culture is just that it's just
very narcissistic very I'm not explain
it but as far as I mean I get it you
have to support a family that's not you
had a break [ __ ] Jake with like a
deep question you couldn't keep it to
like question
boxing-glove the use what type of jump
rope do you see the kid but look it's
going to [ __ ] out you know in other
words he got his man with the same thing
Kennedy got it with except he's alive
and you want to hit him in the head
question I'm sorry should we play Jake
alone for my report what's going on in
the room you know your sylars not around
sometimes you leave it and you want to
live it up a little bit now you want to
get in to beat them you gotta warm up
well you gotta kiss him in the neck
piece you gotta look him in the eye tell
me sweet nothings you wanna you want to
stick a finger in his ass no wonder
you're single your [ __ ] [ __ ] gaming
skills keep it simple like they're you
know do you like ham raps [ __ ] like that
saying you spin it or bucket of these
but outside the ring [ __ ] like that okay
it's the fight game when we got here we
were talking we're comparing the fight
game to the Tommy Cade and then you say
well it's two different things I did
Tommy for 10 years and I never got
punched in the face well then you're
doing family wrong
yes I got punched in the face every
night for the first six [ __ ] years or
at least have felt like it it felt like
it's the same thing
a beaten is a beaten whether it's
emotional or smart or punch to the face
there was some nights I'd rather just
got a punch to the face
and drive home and know that I'm just a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you didn't do comedy and
gathered humiliated in front of 200
people in the [ __ ] room think about
it yeah if I come up to you and an
alleyway and smack in the face nobody
sees it that's a lot different than
getting smacked in the face in front of
your girlfriend I don't know I feel like
it rather bomb oh yeah no it's the same
[ __ ] thing so you know when you talk
about Derek Louie yeah I do comedy your
feed my [ __ ] family now yeah
absolutely specked it as an art right I
definitely respect the lasers art and
this is against Eric Lewis I like
Derrick Lewis it was just I I see it I
see it a little bit in comedy people
look down on you always hear about like
the road hacks or this and that and some
people just it's more of a jar they
don't maybe they don't love it as much
or whatever the reason but it's just had
more of a job to them than an art you
listen man last week I went to Maui and
I was doing helium thank you for coming
out by the way I had a great time
important it's a beautiful city a big
shout out to uh volcano the [ __ ]
Mexican restaurant one of the best Irena
in the country you know I used to go to
Portland in the late 90s and it was a
[ __ ] dark cave of death now it's
alive and kick'n you know as
civilization of deso thank you when I
went to Portland last week this to
comedy clubs there's a popular comedy
club RVs you know a popular comedy club
ileum where I played then there's like a
lesser room that's a cool they don't
really hire outside a certain budget
skal RVs and the guy was there and now
I'm too I can't think of David Crowe I
mean David Crowe started together in
fact the year I did the Seattle comedy
competition
he [ __ ] wanted this guy had
more talent and one thing that I had my
whole [ __ ] body and now when I saw
him I gave him a big hug and I was happy
to see David grow but I learned
something and no matter what we're doing
we're both still part of the same army
well boat still comics I respect them
whether he was doing big fell in love
with the rock or I respect them if he's
doing circuits in Seattle or ever I
still have the utmost respect for him
when I left I was happy to see him I was
happy he came by and said well that's a
20-year relationship I was only 22
[ __ ] years Wow and we both took
different paths he had a family he had
you know close ties this and he didn't
want to leave Seattle me I was a bum I
got chased out every place I lived that
so I settled here you know so for
everybody everybody has a different
situation and everybody has a different
motivation on why they do something it's
easier to judge someone else I think so
it's nice to hear that not everyone does
oh why you know the minute in fighting
writing comedy the minute way you start
getting angry you stop getting angry at
other people's successes is when you
really grow as an artist as much as I
hate calling myself an artist which I'm
not I'm just a dirty comic that does an
art that works on an art I am NOT an
artist right most people consider
themselves but when you're I'm a guy
you're an artist you're an artist and
you express yourself in different ways
you know I can't get an armbar when you
have a gear on and here these guys are
getting on bars with no [ __ ] t-shirts
on and [ __ ] like that it was a I do a
circuit
class at the place where Joey does
jiu-jitsu and he always has something
jiu-jitsu on the TV and so I'm hoping
that he he'll we will never start the
class I watch it and he was it was a
documentary about the the Gracie's and
how they kept going over to Japan and
like finding one guy and like each
different brother would fight him and
one guy had like an hour-long match like
it it's crazy how for like a brawler you
big like heavyweights they just punching
the fight can be over in six seconds but
for someone like jiu-jitsu it's it is an
hour and you have to like it you might
spend ten minutes trying to get your leg
in one spot it's pretty it was pretty
interesting to watch
it's everything's alright you know
boxing is an art when you watch the when
you watch a true pure boxer box it's an
art how they trick you how they know if
I throw a [ __ ] right hook at Jake I
already know how Jake of the react and
I'm gonna keep taking Jake in that
direction and I'm watch he nods I'm
gonna get him with an uppercut it's an
art it's a [ __ ] art and it's
interesting that way it is an art but
like I'm just thinking about we were
talking about kids my mom would never
like we I never watched the WWE it was -
she said was too violent but it's
there's a different look it's
interesting that people are looking at
it now and looking past the violence and
looking at like the skill like that's
that's as much of a sport as any other
sport when I sign a contract to get in
the ring with somebody and fight
organized with wrath and scorekeepers
and whatever I don't really consider it
violence consider it
two people agreeing to fight each other
for money violence I don't know is when
I watch a movie when I watch the narcos
and it's a guy that with an ashtray
that's violence you know I'm saying so
it's a heart absolutely it's an all
right that you express your you know
when you watch Muay Thai I'm all way
type out the guy just doesn't walk up to
the ring he has like a [ __ ] thing and
there's a snake charmer behind and he
goes something does a little dance yeah
and he expresses himself with that dance
before he fights you to show you what
Mabley come from what village he comes
from whatever the [ __ ] have you ever
seen the the haka that they do the
Samoans doing ry no like football teams
do it it's like I get choked up
sometimes
yeah it's pretty it's intense they like
they had like the entire Sugano for the
tribe or what but they all do this like
they're just yelling and like stomping
and like there was one video of the
school doing it for a teacher that was
retiring and it's it's it's I don't know
if it's a song or it's not it's not a
song it's like it's a chain but it's
just it's uh it was it's wild to see you
I'm so I'll have to see if I can find a
good one no please
okay what's going on with you Jake that
was burger talk to me bad [ __ ]
are you retired really gonna do what's
your life about I'm never I mean the
doors not to doors not closed for you
know we'll see I'm not yeah right now
I'm not I'm not planning on fighting
anytime soon so but it's always weird II
sometimes always sometimes the offers
companies you know we don't expect it so
it's gotta be still got mouths to feed
good then you got mouths to feed
it's a different type of pressure yeah
sure I go to Japan and fight [ __ ] some
dude that's an uber driver and he's
gonna the Grim Reaper on this back I did
bit there's so many options as an
ex-fighter that you have it is pretty
cool like is a Brent is an ex-fighter I
don't know if you fought in the UFC but
he fought and it's cool
yeah it's cool to be able to learn from
like an expert like
you get to be a professional fighter at
any level you're an expert I think like
just watching these like because that's
amazing watching like I like watching
the embedded and I see them like working
out I'm like this even if I got in shape
there's no amount of shape that I could
do the workouts that they're doing like
I said look at the highest level that's
pretty [ __ ] amazing to watch I like
it I like watching the whole development
program like the whole I love watching
fighters you for example you always grew
as a fighter you know you always did
something from match to match that was
something different you know I think
that sometimes fighters like old comics
they depend on certain jokes and they
get too dependent on those jokes and
that's what you never want I never want
to go well when I fight Jake I gotta
look for his right hand no I want the
three guys in the room to say no not
only that he's got a mean triangle he's
got a mean [ __ ] guard and he's got a
nasty guillotine I want to be known for
having a couple of [ __ ] weapons it's
great to have a hard punch but guess
what
78% of your cane they hit hard that's
why they're in the [ __ ] you ever see
so your mind is still the strongest
weapon your mind is still happy you have
to say to yourself I'm gonna go into
this fight and I'm gonna make sure Jake
doesn't hit me he doesn't touch my face
I'm gonna keep moving and bobbing and
weaving
it's a weird mindset but an art is an
art is it not we should have not done
those bong hits tonight both bong hits
one called for Lisa I I'm a really bad
influence on you I want to ask you are
you like that little [ __ ] that one who
did you're poor Jake you know I wasn't I
wasn't expecting that
no this
it's 32 percent THC will you pick it
thirty two point six nine Wow thirty two
point six line is directly [ __ ]
dangerous he comes in he comes in every
weekend and every week we have to break
records he said this was lambs breath
and they don't make it anymore the last
of them I tell you what whatever it
takes for you to smoke some [ __ ]
reefer no because I was watching a new
narcos and then the narc was they talked
about a week call sensimilla
and I remember being a young man and the
three weeds we had on the East Coast
because yeah they were moving all those
funds but everybody on the west coast
was getting them the East Coast wasn't
getting that weed we were getting
Colombian red or Panama red Columbian
gold we've called lambs brethren
Jamaicans the Lambs brent was so [ __ ]
good lead it was so [ __ ] good and
there would be 12 spots the city who
solved it by 180 first three 188 and
Amsterdam
well Jamaican they were all little
Jamaican spots nice and every once in a
while they would get a batch so let's
add bumped into Jake and we smoked a
joint why Jake turn that off it's too
strong where'd you get that from I just
got in an hour going on in a third
Street I get on the [ __ ] bus they're
seen by a quarter of it that was that
was always the place when I was growing
up was that one day you'll go to Jamaica
and I'll smoke weed there but you mean
you were smoking it in New Jersey I was
bad and smoked it until high school
no I didn't give a [ __ ] about smoker and
you make Mars I'm gonna [ __ ] if I smoke
in your bathroom I just want to be in
high I know I've been one of those
people that had I wanted you make and it
was the weirdest thing I was shooting
them moving I fired I was shooting this
really awful [ __ ] movie and I knew it
was gonna be awful when they gave me a
script before I flew I kept asking for a
script like it's not really ready yet
and when I got down they had limited
amount of money and I was I couldn't
wait this function
takeaways like I'm like I can't wait to
come on that was two weeks on this movie
and the first thing I did was I will
look I said we'll ask the cab driver and
he goes but they told me not to buy
weaves and the cab drivers so once you
get to the hotel at the hotel by at the
hotel from the Busboys yourself smart
okay so I check and boom boom boom boom
boom I make eye contact with the bellman
I have like five hours ago you're gonna
walk me to the room he goes yeah I'll
walk to the room I said listen where's
the [ __ ] [ __ ] that killed Bob Marley
he goes you want we labor yet he dropped
me off in my room dog you know this
[ __ ] that that's all I said to
him is I want some weed and he goes okay
give me some time you gonna be here I go
yeah he knows my name is whatever Jamal
I'm Joey you [ __ ] left me it wasn't
even 10 minutes I got a knock on my door
he doesn't may I come in and I'm gonna
get he [ __ ] comes in he goes in his
pocket Lee there's no baggie there's no
brown bag there's nothing he pulled out
a [ __ ] I'm holding my fingers out for
you people listening it had to be an 8 a
9 inch torpedo bud holy [ __ ] just one
God was ripped off the [ __ ] tree like
it was just ripped my he just ran to the
plantation and robbed it from somebody
wherever they grow we don't know if it's
a plantation I don't know what it's
called my night it was so nobody I'm not
making Kelly all I know is that he went
and picked it up somewhere the weed
fields and he wanted like 40 [ __ ]
bucks and I don't know if I didn't have
the cash I know my point was that that's
how fast it was but he left I had
rolling papers Jesus [ __ ] broke up the
weed my [ __ ] that smoked it run in the
balcony oh my god [ __ ] up have you
ever been so high they they have to give
you like I drop us on the set because
I'm thinking about my eyes oh yeah like
they must get oh yeah I do that I don't
know if I'm one step ahead of you I do
the [ __ ]
I drops and since I was 35 but put the
[ __ ] wrinkled [ __ ] under my eyes
what's that like the wrinkled stuff see
your eyes won't get wrinkled so you
don't look Chinese I'm Way ahead E what
the [ __ ] you think you're the only thing
I'm a professional I can't be walking
around looking like I'm cheating [ __ ]
child you're Snoop Dogg you'll walk
around looking like he got hit in the
head with a hammer when you're a fat
[ __ ] comic you can't look walk around
looking like you're high all the time
so I would put Visine in my's which is
not the best thing in the world you know
I I can't do it I'm just I'm petrified
he's going on my eyes really yeah my mom
I used to have to sit on me when I used
to get eyedrops what the [ __ ] is wrong
with me I don't like eye drops you still
only use them no I haven't used it
myself I don't think ever so when I got
that Stein that stupid hot tub who put
those I I don't have to put cream in and
you hold out and you'd hold down your
eye lid and put it in it was a I talked
to Steve Simone to the wall yeah I was
like showering sheets it's like
Sebastian did so I'm gonna bring my own
I'm sure it's gonna be fine it would be
nice but I I have bad luck with well
shared beds I get it every time every
time I'm near him I got a start of the
day I'm gonna see him he could be gone
for a week and on the sixth day I'm
gonna start just is he good totally
that's again B&B check we're gonna air
B&B check they killed what [ __ ]
whatever she went they air B&B the
security guard killed they just
identified the body thought she was
missing I was talking to a comic last
night who air B&B this place when he was
at home for two months and he said that
when he got back they had broken the
locks and there were two hookers and
living and they're doing heroin with
guys and there was blood all over his
long so yeah I think you're right
probably don't do an air B&B
like he was renting yeah he was running
his apartment yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ] oh I
don't want no bit my [ __ ] house yeah
you know Jake needs a place to stay for
a week you need a place to stay for a
week you're always welcome but a
stranger in $66
and how creepy you and you won't sustain
some guy's house and sherry star but I
can't [ __ ] stand that [ __ ] I've never
liked that idea since day one yeah and I
heard of making more money than hotels
new what Airbnb yeah people love it
people feel more comfortable I don't
know like what telling people like some
people really that I don't like the feel
of hotels really you know and there's
people who now I bring more stuff like I
bring my kids Teddy but I bring my
daughter's teddy bears really yeah I
don't however she gives me I take it all
out and I put it on their bed you know I
don't put a Bread on bring a picture or
anything but I knew people who I went on
the road with who you called them in
fact I just watched a documentary it was
the one about Lenin skin it and they
were talking about that they had a girl
on the crew that you'd be in a hotel how
and she called you got our room and
she'd rearranged the furniture she'd
hang posters on the room she would burn
candles just to give it that lived in
not that sanitary Four Seasons feel I
mean don't get me wrong it's very nice
to stay at the four seasons when you're
a starving comic it's nice to stand at
Motel 6 cry no but I just always when my
mother died
guys I lived on so many [ __ ] couches
I stayed and so memories people extra
room I stand in so many people's garages
I stayed on so many people that once I
was done with it I was done with it you
know for the first 16 years economy
every time I did something I would have
to do it in Stanley's house and one day
just get sick of me like I can't do it
anymore now I can never stay at
somebody's house Jake loves me he's my
brother but Jake's
I'm gonna say then why is Joey up it -
why does it you know maybe Jake's has
one of those alarms that when you open
the door
think of the house the beach yeah you
know his wife's gonna hear that all
night me going outside and smoking dope
she's got kids so I can't do that you
don't think I get like when I stay at
somebody's house now now I'm forced to
stay up at night cuz I'm not comfortable
oh yeah you're not comfortable even if
you give me my own bedroom like you have
like a spare bedroom mmm
I'm not gonna be comfortable in there I
know they're next door and it'll be at
3:00 in the morning I gotta tiptoe to
the bathroom you what I can't leave the
pee in there so you gotta flush it so
your wife he is that that's a weird
thing that I see a lot of what the
pre-fight stuff is that even for UFC
fights like this like a bunch of guys in
a room like when they go for from the
good when the whole camp goes they don't
each guys they can't really doesn't get
a room what do you think the sea gives
to strengthen Tripp the sky Zone room
it's for guys for a room you're smelling
for different feats yeah
you're [ __ ] smelling jockstraps you
hear him people snore Jesus
yeah you don't know what life is -
you're the hotel room with four people
and there's one bed there's one double
bed you ask for extra pillows and you're
fighting for the [ __ ] you know you
know and your bags that now but that's
all part of the whole thing that toughen
you up that toughen your mental game up
that's all part of it that adds to your
frustration you really in the [ __ ]
what if I put you in the Fred Astaire
suite you know saying what a jacuzzi and
a [ __ ] big king-size bed you might
get soft on me I need you to stay hard
so maybe it's good that you sleep in the
same bed with a guy that looks like me
that's 20 to 40 years old thing I mean
you're 20 and I'm your trainer I'm 55
and you gotta sleep next to me at night
I'm fought and I'm scratching my balls
the whole night I'm watching TV I'm
scratching my balls you're watching my
left hand you just focused on that left
hand cuz you don't want it nowhere close
to you the bed lost in the middle of
night I hug you what happened I'm used
to sleeping with my wife for twenty is
terrifying oh my god Planeta Jake
Ellenberger planet - Jake Ellenberger
what's the report over there brother
what's happening how you feeling tacos
on the way home that's the left away
from the [ __ ] CIA from the bush
regime they just released it but at the
funeral [ __ ] there's this [ __ ] that
killed Bush I gotta give it to the dog
pretty soon you see a little Trevor B
this is a service dog that dude is so
happy
I love sometimes whenever like we're out
and he'll just give it to someone random
I'm like that guy is gonna have a
fucked-up afternoon like sometimes you
like sometimes you like because edibles
and the maids gonna have them like I
haven't loved what I do that I love
leaving edibles for maids do you think
they eat it
have you ever heard that they ate it or
nothing baby yet
they probably eat it go home and pass on
I don't even know what happened yeah oh
my god next day they're like what
happened I don't know something I left
two cookies they look yummy and I ate
them next thing you know I woke up in an
alley I always leave food for them in
the world it was last time I left
[ __ ] beautiful sandwiches from the
beautiful [ __ ] sandwich you think
they he didn't throw it away
oh yeah because Gino brought me
sandwiches then my brother brought me
some Cuban sandwiches oh nice so I had
all Gino sandwiches I had a half of the
Cuban sandwich I left there because
they're Spanish made that I can leave
prosciutto it
so now delete a [ __ ] human sandwich
planet to Jake Ellenberger planet is
Jake Ellenberger where we at with the
status how about this what's your
favorite thing to eat after a fight do
you have anything that's a light one
that hey that's a good one he's high
he's thinking about food right now that
what's your favorite thing to eat after
you fight mmm just what whatever at that
moment it oh it's a by the moment thing
in a ham it's steak burger fries yeah
milkshake any that must be especially
around this time like if you missed
Thanksgiving cuz you're on a fight camp
[ __ ] you like I'm really [ __ ] know
struggling for this what's used what's
the usual fight camp six eight weeks
yeah usually eight when you start
cutting weight at what point of the camp
mmm-hmm weight you probably like three
or four weeks out you know you really
start to pay attention but I'd simply a
monitor more of what you got to get to
sorry and then what you get the wave and
you weigh in you still feel and you
still can't go crazy to be hearing
things Jake no just no listen to the
voices this happens all the time
I just tumblr go away when I got that
high he called me every 60 minutes the
cops called own aunt fun like who I had
the cops gonna call I was just hanging
up on me he would call me back my had
the cops on the calm you don't worry
about nothing
don't say the lines open hang up on it
oh my so after you weigh in well how
much are you allowed to eat yeah
whatever
you can't go first be a big better
because you'll get like stomach cramps
and stuff yeah I mean most I'd say why
a lot of protein well yeah I mean I went
my lunch a kiss like a smile make
believe every three minutes is wave so
we know there's a bee all right this
wave whatever you do can you eat before
you go onstage
yeah well you eat a little bit I've done
but I've never because to me even still
now and you had a funny joke you said
you should just start doing more shows
it's not that I'm like I can eat before
I do a show he's doing more shows it's
true if I was you I'd be doing a show
every hour on the hour at the laundromat
Chandler [ __ ] Chandler and Laurel
next little [ __ ] of Isis on the corner
with the homeless guys that's still not
I wouldn't know about three weeks ago
waiting life rolling papers that's still
Isis oh really he the guy who I've seen
there Lynn it and I played his rock
music he plays like Led Zeppelin he's
Isis because if I rather than and
somebody wanted a so listen people
caught on to you they know you're Isis
so now he's trying to Americanize you
explain the national anthem but they got
a training camp in the back they got
people doing jumping jacks lambs and
[ __ ] back there
Isis is the system 111 the scary place I
did I did something with our buddy Ron
Jude a couple weeks ago or that last
weekend he does like Ally reviews and we
were in an alley and a homeless guy you
look at the end of the videos a homeless
guy like being like get the [ __ ] out of
here sometimes like the that's something
that I I tried ten I try to give them
something 50 cents a quarter whatever I
have but something like there was just
one person who got stabbed
this lady got stabbed giving no up by
stay away from homeless people now to a
different level now there's one guy
around here I gave him a 20 he's a big
black guy should say [ __ ] ever gets deep
long sent him loose on a [ __ ] I
know for him allows he'll strangle you
to death but I got him on the 20 program
I get my hundred I get sick of onion
he's got a black scarf he smells bad but
he smiles he knows what my wife and kid
look like so I told him you see him in a
jam you choke that [ __ ]
every time I see him I put a 20 you guys
see when he looks at the 20 I'll beat
his eyes get well that's legal weekly
not on drugs he's not on drugs doesn't
drink alcohol he just probably went to a
war I guarantee you he's a veteran I
know for a fact he's a veteran just by
his look and his demeanor that's really
sad and it's no longer that Avenue he's
probably 36 or something so he's a
veteran of one of the Gulf Wars or
something I could tell you just has
mental issues how can you not coming
back from one of those things but every
time I see him he's one of the guys I
really take care of and there's a new
guy next the wizard meeting place really
there's a new guy over there that's
really interesting sometimes I pull over
and I watch his art he's art and I gave
my ten bucks last time I went just to
look at his art he asked me to buy a
piece that was really nice but I got
enough [ __ ] at the house I can't if I'd
bring some oh my wife will kill me
where did you get this from almost dude
no no right there instead of making the
straight to Lankershim right answer
right down that lizard street yeah
exactly I'm pull the car right over he's
got like he's homeless he lives there
he's got like a little art exhibit and
you know looking at it from I know it
just made me I saw he's black and I saw
nice white people talking at all like
people walking past them with dogs
stopping I always take that route when I
go to Brett's
rather they go to Muay Thai okay you go
now I need you to I cut down that way
and go down the side street so I started
seeing them and the other dad had time
so I actually pulled over and asked them
a few questions I mean as much as I mean
I I don't know if I could survive like
it shows you how strong some people can
be because I don't I'm not a suicide
person I don't think but like to be able
to survive being homeless is something
that not everyone can do I think
well it's like I told you from ninety
you know 97 and a half there maybe 99 I
would send my homeless especially out
here so what I would do is put myself on
the road which is still homeless just
still gives you the homeless effect you
know on the road you have those four
nights that you work but you have three
nights that are off you can't spend all
the money you just mean I'm waiving that
money goes to you can't stay you know so
if you're in a one-nighter yeah the
first night he's staying your car and
you saved the 40 bucks so you're
basically homeless then the second day
you break down and I mean if you could
check on that two o'clock you squeeze
every hour that hotel oh yeah they're
150 firing food upstairs with you you
don't leave that room
you just [ __ ] bathe all day and clean
your toes you know that you just mix it
up you learn how to mix it up but I was
physically homeless for a while when I
got hooked on drugs and what am i mean
how physically homeless was I four or
five days just staying outside taking
showers at friend's house
yeah that's all I would check into a
hotel for a week and then I would stay
two days out hey Liz Ellen is a
different kind of homeless though well I
was never homeless like that yeah the
home when you go down listen every city
right now every time I go to see when I
go to these cities I look a little out
of the things I look at the construction
in the city I see how much construction
there is going on in this country right
now construction is big man means money
yeah and he city I go to they're
building buildings so I see a lot of
construction but I also see a lot of
homeless you know you don't know what
homeless is did you go to San Francisco
oh yeah you don't know what home
assist you in a Portland you know look
matters it's part of a counterculture
it's mixed with pills and heroin it's
just part of this culture you know
they're still runaways there's all this
stuff's to lose this this will always
exist but the populations are getting
bigger the other factor to that is
socio-economic some of these rents are
so high you know you have to if I was
young and single right now I'd really
consider investing in an RV it's like
twenty thousand dollars yeah yeah might
as well it's a couple years lengths I
see an RV finding an RV park we just
pull up to an RV park your thing they
have a laundromat in there a breakfast
place and their movie theater in there
they have them so like places I think
that one malleable you know really Wow
yeah yeah I mean it's uh but there's
people out here who just parking on the
street and there's a lot of there's a
comic oh just went the other night who
lives in this car and he just got
totaled so he's like he they give him a
rental but he hasn't lived in the rental
it's uh there was a story that I saw
that they that they're opening up
parking lots in LA because there's so
many people who are living in their car
so it's like a safe place they can get a
permit to park there it's a little safer
than just parking on the street I
remember those days
hmm I'm going in my car on Vista like I
would it was like I would overstay my
welcome at Josh wolfs I wouldn't
overstay my welcome at ralphie's there
was some nights where I was like you
know what I'm not in the mood to
embarrass myself or anybody else I'm
just gonna sleep on my car this is 20
years ago 1998 Wow and I would pull over
on Vista and I would go under a tree or
something and I would lock my doors and
open up the sunroof
and just make the driver's seat fall all
the way back and I could figure out the
way I could lay on my side listen it
wasn't a Sealy Posturepedic but I could
sleep a lot I mean it was horrible you
got horrible sleep you sleep I'd sleep
three hours and then I'd move into the
back seat the back seat I have to sleep
on my back with my light with my knees
up and my feet you know it was a Nissan
or Sentra or something like that
thank God I'm short that's uh and did
cops mess with you no never never not
one time the cop below police ain't not
allowed to sleep in his are wise I
stirred my being a coach and horses and
getting so coked up one night and I had
nowhere to go and I still remember right
there being on Vista and it had to be
11:30 and I had people walking their
dogs and I'm in my car with a blanket
over me jerkin off [ __ ] beer you know
how embarrassing that is looking back at
it now like what a blanket over me with
the air conditioner on with the sunroof
open oh you did the AC on the whole
night some nights yeah especially out
here Sun nights and when I first started
doing comedy those Tribble ones oh my
god I was I trained myself out of sleep
and you learn a lot like you learn how
to go to bus state wha train train truck
stop suck stops like there's the ones
that wit and they pump gas there and you
know you could take a shower there and
buy food then they have like a Subway
sandwich Annette DOS okay it's the one
that's like a part like a restaurant
it's just enter here trucks go this way
you go that way those are the ones that
always worried me but it slept in twenty
or thirty of them you get up in the
morning you brush your teeth to put hot
water on your face you pee you walk
around
you know what we have a lot of truck
drivers I'm sure to listen this what
about them in those days I would drink
the soda and have a bag of Cheetos for
breakfast because that's what I can
afford there was no two eggs of bacon
all right yeah hard lentil breakfast you
know so many nights I slept in the
[ __ ] rest area and then there were
nights when I would I still don't know
one particular night it was during the
final four like during march man right
yeah that did something I did y'see
Idaho Boise had a comedy club at the
time but they also had a one-nighter on
the Saturday night so my plan was to in
between shows as a feature act go over
and showcase at the funny bone and Boise
City no I'm saying yes he could come
back so you would go up I would go up
the headliner would do 45 and there's an
hour so I would have an hour and 45
minutes for the show started again I
would run over to the Boise improv the
Boise funny bone and do a showcase for
the lady then come back but that night I
had to do that but I also had a problem
I had visitation that next Sunday two
o'clock in the morning and it was a 12
hour drive from where I was to Boulder
Colorado [ __ ] I will never forget that
night for as long as I live and in those
days I wasn't doing coke on the road I
couldn't afford it I would eat half a
box of nodoz oh and just drink Mountain
Dews and I can't tell you how bad you
feel like I can't tell you how bad you
feel but I still remember it it would be
slowing or like shitty weather so I
couldn't pull over and just turn the car
off but you call in but I have to pull
over and pull with the heat and I
remember that particularly like pulling
over but not
the restaurant just pulling over the
side of a road holy [ __ ] um no forget
this and letting the seat drop turning
my headlights off and just sweeping
dozing off and the car was on and I'll
never forget opening my eyes and popping
up and thinking that I had lost control
the car he fell asleep driving and I
fell asleep driving I think I got to
that point that you would fall asleep
driving the most I've done I think is
like eight hours twelve is a [ __ ]
while the time I was on the road as a
driver as a comic I got so good and
efficient at it because my plan was
short and simple I could do everything I
wanted once the tank of gas is finished
I wouldn't tank the tank there was no
stopping in between tanks I stopped when
the tank was empty cuz you had to get 12
hours in the other [ __ ] I had to get
eight hours nine hours it could be three
hours it could be six hours it didn't
matter I'd get up in the morning I get a
good meal in me you know especially if I
did a triple rather some you got 20% off
of breakfast you have to be careful you
can't have like pancakes coz then you
fall asleep no driving oh no I wouldn't
need pancakes anyway I would just he'd
like a good hearty breakfast because
you're living on the road you don't need
solid meals yeah okay you know on those
calmly roads at first there was a week
that I'll never forget this I got no
reason to lie on anybody there was a
week so I stayed in Saginaw Michigan
that all I ain't was two for a dollar
hot dogs from the supermarket and subway
veggie and cheese sandwich like I
budgeted my money like I knew I wasn't
picking up money till Friday and it was
a Sunday I'd already bought coke I'd
enough weed to hold me Oh for a week now
I had it make it on and that's when you
eat all the oranges and
apples Navabi all those orange is it
good those days when you go out stairs
in the middle lane you get like two
apples or oranges in a bag of Doritos
and bending for a dollar it was that
type of [ __ ] like those veggies and
cheese sandwiches I would buy a footlong
and eat one for lunch and the other for
breakfast and pray to God they would
offer me food at the club free
did they ever offer you food you took in
then they asked for money oh yeah
oh no yeah they give you a tab at the
end of the night and you you know it's
like 50% off you know a lot of places
fed you for free
especially like a burger or something
and some places were very nice what a
[ __ ] commie Kyle gave you something
ago that saved you when I was your
breakfast
that was your breakfast I don't give a
[ __ ] what it was whose chicken fingers
mozzarella sticks whatever they gave you
that's why I went from being 240 to 400
pounds I mean when I got off the road
I was probably 320 I'm not gonna blame
it all on the road but it was the
beginning of a healthy diet
going off the rails she's not really
exercising if you're just doing the gig
drive and eating after a while I brought
a basketball I had a frisbee
how do you play frisbee by yourself
okay so the other cop you will always
work for another comic after some reason
in those days the Red Roof Inn used to
have like a little basketball court
also when you work for Tribble you
worked a lot of retro fitness so I would
just take like jump shots and [ __ ] like
that
yeah otherwise you're just gonna do
nothing what any of those things listed
acting you know how do you feel if
you're fighting in the UFC event and
you're cold
and you get there at seven o'clock
that's three hours to kill you I can't
imagine that my mind guy yeah what would
you do I go to sleep like get the locker
room I you fall asleep on the locker
room yeah like it's best it was when I
was at my best fall sleep good nap you
know you just take the locker room yeah
yeah all the mats exactly well guys were
around you warming up to all punches
yeah get headphones just try to ignore
you know because sometimes like if
you're fighting internationally don't
you find it like 1:00 in the morning
sometimes yeah yeah super lay that's
wild to yet it is it's it would suck to
fight it like 2:00 in the morning
save to practice I always notice that I
cuz I used to hate when I was growing up
I used to hate when people would hand
test back in school because my lip my
name is saya time towards the end I have
to sit there waiting wondering when I
got on the test so I always think that
Darlie fights like how long ago like how
Conor McGregor and could be you felt
it's like a two three four hour
experience that they always show them
walking into the arena I'm like that
name I I can't imagine falling asleep
that's wild but just being able to like
calm yourself down but I guess that's
why you're a fighter
I could never calm myself down enough to
just sleep did you have to like do like
a diva workout to get yourself jazzed up
because sometimes if I have a mess up
and take a nap too soon before like a
comedy show I feel like I'm a little bit
low energy on stage I have to plan it
out right and wake up early enough and
really wake up before I can't wake up
and go to an open mic it's not gonna go
great yeah yeah yeah it's
I'll ask you again another do you ever
do that do you ever [ __ ] up with your
naps and like your low-energy
when I first started out the triple run
all this stuff like that I would
Nappanee afternoon there was a couple
nights at the phone rang yeah and they
were like hey where are you were about
to start the show
this is right now I was never I drank
Cuban coffee as a kid from time to time
as a goof because of the sweetness of it
it's all sir but I didn't drink coffee
so 1999
I still don't drink coffee now is
whatever I was in 1999 3700 how really
you started that way yeah I was never a
coffee drink but you have to you had to
you found like the caffeine I found it
to wake up to drive in between drives
and then I fell in love with it with the
smoking cigarettes and weed aspect of it
really it's better Oh a cup of coffee
with a joint stop it really I'll have to
try but you're drinkable that if you
drink it with milk informal a beautiful
black with that cancer sugar
oh you can't desert okay stevia the
[ __ ] old cancer sugar it's all gonna
kill you you brought something so that's
gonna get humiliated by that type of
[ __ ] whether you're small intestine
you're big intestine your colon affects
something it really does so there is the
alternative for 2000 years everybody
drank sugar like it was cocaine all of a
sudden now sugar is the [ __ ] enemy you
know and it's weird I don't need
anything sweet at night very self I
don't want that sugar of my bloodstream
at night for me to flip on the diabetic
side so I watch that a lot you know I if
I eat sugar I'll try to eat it early so
I could burn it throughout the day
that's smart
it's funny we were talking about cereals
before we didn't know at the time
what you were really putting into your
body at that age
yeah we're about when they used to show
like compartment complete breakfast on
cereal with orange juice and toast with
jelly on you like that's all sugar that
whole thing
my mom would never that's why I fell in
love with it because my mom would all
like him as a kid you like my mom always
makes breakfast I never get cereal
looking back I'm like that [ __ ]
pretty cool but uh I I wasn't allowed to
have it
it was like an after-school snack a real
yeah we would have like Cheerios or cake
like I still love kicks
I have kicks at house at the house right
now we can only have like through loops
or something I was looking after school
snack it was never for breakfast so
Froot Loops with milk or fruit was
playing I'll do both but I I mean I
prefer it would look but think about it
we were a lot to sit neither half a box
of [ __ ] I loved Cocoa Krispies oh
yeah
I will [ __ ] anything that makes the milk
chocolate it was that Oh Count Chocula
but I don't know which one was I think
it was I was a Cocoa Krispies guy the
second my daughter eats Cocoa Krispies
from time to time they want so long in a
small bowl I'm a little soggy yeah
listen to him crack no way for them to
get the perfect sogginess I love all
that [ __ ] shredded wheat sure we could
my favorite I like life because I have
you have life all life is famine life
that's zero that's when I get all the
time life is rocks in German you think
it's healthy look kindly but really not
you not [ __ ] beaten frosted flakes
right I got box before I eat you live
but there was a time I got a box of
frosted
oh yeah cut out my tongue ah yeah with
the same no you just pour a little bit
more I took em no get [ __ ] it's just
sugar milk yeah happens I'll get high
and I won't want to go to the fridge to
get more milk but I bring the box
because you have to take care of the
rest of the milk and then I'll just
start shopping drop it on my face cuz
it's I love it I wake up next to a pile
honey nut cheerios I love I used to take
like regular ice
krispies with no sugar and put like
sweet low on it that's like that's what
I would do to get a little sweeter when
you were a kid did you ever like any
healthy cereals at all healthy like how
old were you the first time now you said
[ __ ] it I'll eat the special cake well
that was a kid if you hit me with
special care sue you I [ __ ] hated
Special K really Cheerios the regular
ones oh I [ __ ] I like very much area
I liked everything with sugar it is oh
yeah and I'm sure you know once you go
to prison once you go to prison you
might have a like Special K what's the
other one there was another one that was
um what's the American one that the box
is yellow no weenies
we leave yet we these and pops when I
got when I went to prison there was one
before I got locked up
iron man cereal what was more like sweet
always delicious I used to mix that with
Wheaties I love mixing to friends oh
that's the [ __ ] that's when you know
you're a bank daddy I'm a there's part
of it I it's just as true story one time
I ran out of milk so I had sugar-free
pudding and it was the same calories as
a cup of milk
I took kicks and chocolate pudding and I
mixed it together it's a it's amazing
it's there's nothing like I like putting
cereal and ice in ice cream that works
but if you have put it on ice cream oh
yeah how much your fat [ __ ] that'll work
in Tom and Jerry's Oh everybody I talked
it in fact I talked to a guy this woman
that told me I just had a whole box area
with [ __ ] ice cream you don't do it
every time but if you if you have a pint
and then you're like oh [ __ ] I have
cereal that's well you you weird [ __ ]
when yours I don't eat it when I'm a
sober eating ice cream like ice creams
enough but when you're stoned you just
start looking in the rest of the cabinet
so I oh this will work and I lots that's
how I being stoned wait you have the
mentality of a fat [ __ ] which I had for
years you know I still have the
mentality you never lose it but when I
moved in with Terry there was a point I
think in 2004 after I shot The Longest
Yard was when I saw the films and I was
like wait a second something's not right
you know I gotta find the hurt healthier
alternative this at that time I was
eating four or five eggs sunny-side up
half a loaf or [ __ ] Wonder Bread
bother on every inch until it dripped
off your toast and we make a whole
package of Oscar Meyer bacon so I can't
go conclusion I go on a wheat line I
still eat the worst thing in the world
it was haagen-dazs frozen vanilla yogurt
have you ever tasted
haagen-dazs frozen tavella yogurt no
it's a good to come squirts out of yes
because they do they have a heart in
front of it now the whole thing so for a
month
me and my wife would split the container
of haagen-dazs frozen yogurt with
granola and strawberries and in the
morning in the mornings oh my god I'll
never forget getting on the scale gave
him like 16 pounds and then she got the
scale and we look at each other we're
like oh what's going on
like what is the meaning of this how did
all this happen
the [ __ ] calories in that frozen
vanilla yogurt and granola is no granola
there's no walk in the park either
yeah that helped either bang yeah I know
that's why I had to stay away from those
acai bowls those awesome old so I even
[ __ ] you know it burns me up
I love when I see two medium chubby
chicks with yoga pants walking like a
half a mile ago Starbucks coffee they
did so good by walking the mile to a
half a mile to Starbucks but then they
get one of those milkshake drinks and
frappuccinos or something walks up the
whole walk like sometimes I look at
those drinks and I can't believe like
I'm a fat [ __ ] yeah and I don't want
those tricks they give them the kid
that's when I'm crazy every six months
I'm not gonna lie to you I go to the
coffee brain and I get their signature
but it's like guys it's been maybe years
since I have you don't believe the
chocolate syrup and end sound oh this is
the coffee with the ice cubes and they
put expresso beans and they put
maraschino cherries
Wow so when you're drinking the coffee
they express their needs and the
maraschino cherries get caught in the
straw all my goodness with whipped cream
on top
I love akron and they put chocolate
served and you mix the whipped cream
with the coffee I can't lie the add
those once a year nice like they're on
Lancashire and Riverside that thing no
lenger Shemin right next to the gym
right no there's a coffee bean on
Lancashire hey oh yeah no I know
definitely driving my gas station right
yeah there's like a shitty road could
beat the hunger maybe whoever's I think
you're right right next to the your
favorite Zankou chicken and the rice
yeah where's the week though right
across the street Riverside and like
other side the street you're right thank
you yep trust me I know where I know
where the McDonald's are there's an
alley - right yeah the 134 134
yeah I can't ride nobody I love those
and I was hooked on flat whites for a
while they're not that bad
if you look I'm up on weight watch these
day like three points what about hot
chocolate okay
oh yeah I like hot chocolate is don't
like I dropped it off let mine flopped
on hot chocolate but I would make it
with water but if you make it with milk
oh my god I get those Hershey's and I
get three or four packs really oh yeah
[ __ ] you and your [ __ ] [ __ ] you and
your [ __ ] where you at
yeah call me when you're outside don't
be wasting my time I'm on don't wanna
pack
[ __ ] you're gonna show up with a
kilo and folks show up with a kilo time
this there's no there's no code just
call me in the gate open up alright bye
what we talking about you would take it
four packs of hot chocolate I would take
four packs of hot chocolate and get a
little bigger cup and put half milk and
half water it's still really good really
[ __ ] thick like what's the swiftness
of the marshmallow oh the small ones
cueing your marshmallows I put my own
one of the small ones they absorb it a
little bit oh my god I tell you what
else is a great [ __ ] cereal what's
the one with the little marshmallows
Lucky Charms oh [ __ ] that [ __ ]
oh that's the diabetic that's it now
with Amazon they're trying to kill you
could they sell just bags of just a
marshmallows yeah no cereal at all try
to kill you they don't [ __ ] around you
can buy bags of just whatever color
starbursts you like Amazon the devil
they like their evil no let's go back to
the Lucky Charms lucky chomp so you just
get the little purple hearts and all
that [ __ ] yeah just a bob just a big bag
of Mars for the moon oh yeah add me your
Cheerios if you like Cheerios better I
guess that's oh I love it I love cereal
fruit the one thing I never got and I
kind of want to try it now is like the
generic cereal mmm I was lucky we always
got the name but the big bags of what
fruit circles or whatever looks like the
generic fruit loops
that's because the the cereal I that's
something you don't realize to the kids
heroes not gonna expensive it's like
four or five bucks don't fart on me I
won't be infamous Jake is here he's
[ __ ] up enough
Jake stars one of my first night he
won't know what to do
oh my god
it's uh yeah it's dangerous living it
cuz I didn't grow up in a place where
there was late-night food I couldn't go
out like that was you broke the [ __ ]
boss
no but the suburbs I'm 45 minutes from
Boston my town was so white they
wouldn't allow fast food places it was
talent outside of it
that you could go to but there was
nothing what they didn't allow Drive
force was what we're in the kafar
American close to it I mean not my town
was was upper-middle class
but like the other ones we're close like
nine or ten fast-food places brings on
your property value yeah so maybe they
didn't want the fast food and yeah
that's exactly what it was yeah I think
or but you said there was no
drive-through Z no Drive no Drive thrus
the Dunkin Donuts didn't have a
drive-through Dunkin Donuts that that is
something that I'm regretting with a
comic whose dad owns like a chain like
I'm Frank a bunch of franchises and my
childhood is one regular glazed one
chocolate glazed and a hot chocolate
like my dad might bring my brother and I
and my mom would bring my brother and I
and he'd sit then they'll be like 18 old
guys in a corner talking cuz they go to
the Dunkin Donuts every day I love that
one chocolate glazed one right at least
Mama's Dunkin Donuts isn't Dunkin donut
and that's well yeah doesn't taste the
same
the donuts is just god [ __ ] awful you
know when I worked the stress factory I
[ __ ] love it because I'm thirty feet
from a Dunkin Donuts and I get the
coffee and you first thought you can't
drink the coffee for ten minutes because
it's gold ring it's like a view
preserving or in the coffee on the bone
yeah it is the hottest coffee that they
sell so I will stand outside in the cold
weather with the coffee and not to cool
the coffee down you have to pour a
little bit down and take the lid off it
if not that coffee never cools down but
the donut is goddamn awful yeah and I'm
a fat [ __ ] that goddamn off
yeah goddamn wall yum yum donuts is way
better yum Yum's is way better they cook
it right there on a place in Burbank
yeah Magnolia we used to go you have to
go early because they're gonna blueberry
filled donut to his [ __ ] phenomenal
you know at this age listen I drink
water Jake and I gain weight at 56 my
metabolism is so [ __ ] horrible don't
have to stay away from all that [ __ ]
like I'm stuck I've been stuck on my
weight watchers weight for [ __ ]
months I don't know if it's the weights
lifting the heavy weights but well
you're working out a lot you're looking
skinnier it's uh it's really weird I'm
looking thinner but I'm not dropping
away I'm burning the fat and throwing
the punches and kicks the lifting has
really helped put my metabolism this
[ __ ] even with the Muay Thai
conditioning and the ropes and the whole
thing did you have metabolism when you
were younger Jesus Christ I never had it
all no I wrote a bike you know you do so
much that you you keep it at such a high
level and that's why people get fat
because they slow down they continue to
eat the [ __ ] they were eating before and
all of a sudden it's like you're a
hundred pounds overweight you can't
figure out what happened yeah happens
put your lifestyle change you know I saw
it early on my mom sold the bar when she
lost the bar the weight gained after a
year was amazing yeah she used to be on
her feet all day walk around they
walking around walking steps carrying
ice talking to people it's a big
lifestyle change different that's uh
it's scary how quickly you can gain
weight I always hated you what have you
always been in shape Jake no no really
no no I was younger I mean I was active
but in between fights you let yourself
go not really I mean you know you eat a
lot more freely but I wouldn't just say
like let go anything but you're still
getting healthy yeah but maybe you have
some brighter
passed every once in a while that's it
exactly listen if you eat two pieces of
if you have two eggs and you scramble
and you put ketchup on and you eat two
pieces of white bread it's not the end
of the world goddess it's the seven
pieces of white bread a day mmm
that'd kill you that's true but in like
especially with Dean it shows me how
much even like if you can if you can cut
it completely out how much it helps cuz
Dean's skinny now and he just doesn't
have bread he has like brown wife's
every once a while
got scared Dean got diagnosed with
diabetes and Dean had a make up a
decision and Dean knew that he's a candy
guy do you know tight he was and oh yeah
what's better than candy so he has no I
made sugar from this but you know what
man people are finding out great things
about little Asian over their diets yeah
listen
don't get me wrong in one form of
another this sugar and everything
especially when you eat out of the house
I know one of the most sugary things
just ketchup isn't it oh yeah to make a
question - doesn't taste like that
there's that even Brent was telling me
like he'll go to like Thai places or
Chinese places and tell them make make
the food but don't put sugar on the
sauce like if you get like Kung Pao or
stuff like they just put sugar straight
in the sauce mm-hmm you can now you
can't yeah yeah and that's we made jokes
like they put heart stuff on the boxes
but you grow up thinking fruits okay and
then you tell me like oh no yeah it's
really not okay like a lot like I don't
you can't really eat an orange you can
it's better than maybe a candy bar but
not really you can eat two thousand
oranges you could eat two thousand
bladders you can eat three thousand
apples take great for you the confusion
that people have is when they drink
smoothies and acai bowls and again I
didn't notice that you have a saliva
that when you eat a fruit that saliva
convert
that sugar before it hits your system
but when you blend the fruit in
overpasses that saliva so when you eat
an acai beau even though they blend of
bananas and goji berries and blueberries
and all these fruits are usually great
fee and they're high in antioxidants and
all this [ __ ] once you put it together
you have a big result of sugar yeah what
about that place on Hollywood with the
juice and the sandwiches they like the
one I used to get was like orange honey
you know the oranges of honey and cream
it's delicious but that must be terrible
I had ice have two of those a day well I
got up to four hundred and eighteen
pounds if I really look back and look at
the path to it I would go to that place
and have one juice there take two home
and one for my wife take two home for
yourself
yeah and lie to her about the one I had
there not lie but I wouldn't mention it
right like I'd say I didn't have
anything that I just wouldn't really
mention it I went from working out a lot
Lee up to 1995 to doing nothing to just
and then when I moved in at least in
Seattle I was semi active once I'm
telling my only priority was Kylie and I
hate freely and I hate dreary you know I
hate a poor man's lunch I used to go to
Wendy's on Sunset and get the one D jr.
they had at some 99 cents when you're a
comic and you got three bucks are you
[ __ ] kidding me
three of those what's the big whopper
what's up Wendy's Burger and I have
junior Bacon's I'm just a junior
cheeseburger on your walk whatever they
have with junior
they had a value menu of a dollar you
know hos walked a lunch special five
dollars and 45 cents
you still know the bread it's a place
you know for [ __ ] shrimp and lobster
sauce shrimp
somebody's [ __ ] on the town and I was
a sea monkey that became mission and
they give you an egg roll a bowl of soup
a small salad a cup of white rice or
fried rice and an entree and then a cup
of ice cream or fortunately with dessert
ice and your bro comic that's what
you're gonna eat
you're not gonna eat great food right I
would go to Pollo Loco on La Brea and
sunset every other day and eat that
[ __ ] time in his chicken those the
chickens that have been beaten and
abused often they were taken from their
mothers those four chickens are horrible
at poyo of them you think they're beaten
up for a fact that chickens and nobody
else wants and you're probably right
it's upsetting the things I like I don't
know how they rate chickens it's not a
guarantee for your love those chickens
when you you know when you got a little
chicken places you have to take all the
meat off and look at the bone that's
when you see the abuse once you bite
into it look like when you go to pipe
buy these chickens right those chickens
have been physically abused
psychologically you could tell by the
inside I had no idea I was chicken
walking distance from the house yeah I
applaud John the control I'm cool I'm
not just have never been there but I
feel like the strips I don't get like a
whole big if I wake up and smell that
[ __ ] early in the morning it's just a
countdown the one wake up it's just a
countdown the one they start frying
chicken at 10 o'clock over there yeah
well the one that gets me is because I
have a turn my building I hate it when
one of my neighbors gets pizza delivered
or has Chinese food and you can get in
the elevator they smell it that's when I
go crazy what's the matter you crazy for
whatever they whatever they get look if
I if I'm in the elevator with like a
Pizza Hut guy I can take like I have to
like control myself and do not go get
pizza harder or run down that's
disgusting
I see a pizza a guy pray for his soul
and whoever's gonna deliver it that's
what I [ __ ] do Jake Ellenberger
checking in with you what's going on put
in how you feeling my man yeah mom yeah
halfway there yeah you just look I'm
gonna stop at all these places you're
mentioning on the way home only a pizza
chicken here maybe there's a thing
that's messed up cuz it's getting kind
of weird like I like we talked about all
the disgusting things I like but now all
especially the Instagram they have
really terrible things they have
something called the Philly taco well
they get a big cheese pizza slice and a
cheesesteak and they roll the
cheesesteak up in the pizza and you're
supposed to eat it at once that's it's
too much I'll find a necessity
mmm yeah I don't find the necessity and
again I'm a fat [ __ ] yeah exactly I
don't find I enjoy the slice of cheese
pizza by itself what is the point of
puttin the [ __ ] take you know it was
[ __ ] I drove in Hollywood and I went
to long round I realized that that place
was closed I don't know if it was closed
at night fat cells yeah
oh no it says open they're running the
reason why I'm laughing is I saw on
Facebook that they're wearing a deal now
so that maybe they aren't doing too well
or they're giving you two sandwiches for
the price of one because that's I love
mozzarella sticks but I don't want to
put it in a sandwich I'll get a side of
mozzarella sticks but I don't need it in
the sandwich last time I had a
mozzarella stick oh so good I had a
[ __ ] hat with a propeller on I had a
minimum and I don't really drink so they
said the mozzarella sticks were good
that robber in place oh yeah
it was good there's marinara tomato
juice you know it's good I saw I saw a
comic dip it in ranch month I just got
my see ranch now I just think of you
yeah that's a good I wonder what would
happen that but the night it was funny I
I did something I never ever
and I gave the waitress my number she
didn't call but I saw her in there the
whole night and then as soon as I gave
her my number she never came in again I
really I realized me probably eating
mozzarella sticks probably isn't the the
most inviting sight but you've given her
a number wasn't the most inviting I
don't know would you say that we give
her a number what do you mean what are
you saying I said I think you're cute if
you want to get a drink here's my number
hang on a Koi you gotta ask her for her
number see I was drawing the show or
trying to be I'm also kind of a [ __ ]
but uh she took that dumb and threw it
away yeah I get your digits let me take
you come by you know beautiful evening
of dinner and a comedy show afterward
yeah and I've been smarter that's a
smart thing not sure you got you know
what a [ __ ] you think but then again
hung up and I know but Mike doesn't make
it look like I'm that funny well no it
doesn't make a difference for least you
got heart and balls she sees you for
what you are yeah you got some [ __ ]
schmuck we should get it on stage some
women just watching you on stage turns
them on yeah that's pretty cool
I bet you used to get a lot of fan mail
and dirty ones yeah I would say we love
when you walk up with you takes his
shirt off and they lovin think cheer for
him don't need to pick a shirt
he's got style class mink young Boudica
personality I'm saying but he is the
muscle that you can see through the
shirt that's that's when you know you're
in a good shape she's got the main
muscle addictive that we have no JPB
call or uptown like and me it's a lot
bigger got a big you know somebody that
you can go with your wife for get it
balanced about five years altogether
yeah hmm and how long did it take you to
marry mmm Oh kind of like right now
we're in the process so I'm getting yeah
yeah like old dude the wedding you know
I really gonna do a baby thing I would I
don't know no you already have two kids
hey let's go down to justice to the
peace I'm saving 10 G's it I'm gonna
walk around you and a white dress on
your
microphone so you can well you came here
we had two kids on we're going to the
courthouse when I'm timing for a big
wedding know once you once you split a
kid out why we lying to these poor
people good poster out of them I needed
vote I want a black pickup my keys a
toaster you know like cheese toast not
really I just like regular toast in you
pop it in nice little cheese toasties
egg but there put some pepperoni on it
you happy Jake yeah be miss fighting
what do you want to do bro are you well
you're in limbo right a more ways than
one
I don't know man I don't know him
I mean Jake yeah 31 and 1516 14 that's
44 [ __ ] fights Jane fights that's a
lot of fights you still alert god bless
you yeah thank you until you came in
here yeah this house I got the weed that
gives you PTSD yeah I'm telling you you
smoked it also you like chocolate down
yeah in CTE CTE or PTSD both beep the
[ __ ] thing that oh Jesus Christ
uh microphone picked it up I think it
open now I hope so
41 fight so whatever the [ __ ] told her
right 31 in 1526 fights on the one you
started 2005 so yeah 13 years long time
I see I always had you down for college
collegiate wrestler
I did not note oh the podcast you took
wrestling up at the age of 20 mmm so you
took a blessing at the same time he was
starting oh yeah
just gotta started turning yet so that's
it it all happened so fast even
competing you'd be like when a fight
opportunity opportunity
so [ __ ] 15 years later you know it's
what was your first competition
jujitsu boxing yeah I think jujitsu and
how did you do yeah I did good daddy
great but I was always how much time I
wanna spend when I was one you know MMA
it was always about MMA so I don't know
what made you jump into MMA deep
question did you have options were you
called are you college educated you have
a degree yeah I'm gonna had options but
it was like it was the most dating you
know so it's well I mean what I always
thought because we talked about what it
thinks to bomb it stings to get punched
in the face how great is it when you
knock somebody out
like that feeling there must be nothing
like that when you knock somebody out
that has to be pretty [ __ ] bad-ass
he's still gone you know I got the [ __ ]
that [ __ ] they gave the woods on the
last day
Kate Quigley's the studio by the way
ladies and gentlemen she was in town
doing her house right ah so she decided
to stop and say hello and just look good
over there in the corner is [ __ ]
the place smells like fruit now remenber
gonna feel a lot more warm yeah Jake's
going through changes in the [ __ ] out of
all the disciplines what's your favorite
mmm tell him but we don't talk about you
between video game watching you watch
Lily enjoy like the ability to box do
you really enjoy the rest let me ask for
coming you you've had KO you've had
submissions mmm
you've won by split decisions I mean you
know you're like yeah I don't remember
that one [ __ ] thing
[ __ ] in 84 and nexon almond [ __ ]
Vegas having coffee with Dana White for
lunch talk it's gonna be alright I guess
at a star that I just took yeah I
thought that you lived on lawrence
county from time to time do you want
about money in between yeah you take a
vape pen probably a little pen you have
a pen I I hit it I said I don't [ __ ]
know Tiger this weed is too much
this would they give some people just to
shut him up sometimes agree trying to
communicate to me Louie we can medium
leaves it the THC media do that to me
sometimes like invite you like you did
it to me earlier if I start getting too
talky and I if I if I start asking
questions
he'll just pass joints I love I love
when someone comes into like a green
room or an office and starts asking you
questions and out of nowhere you have an
animal you're a butt joint usually small
business and it just shows people it
slows down my job is just Laurie I was
going on in your day whatever you walked
into that threshold thinking that's what
a hostess job is to me if you really
think about it think about what all a
good you anybody here watching Miley's
game know he's a busy man is about a
chick who's the skier in the Olympics
and she breaks her [ __ ] legs and she
moves to LA to be a model but she gets a
job working for a guy that runs poker
games at night and she's real personable
and whatever you know when you come on
the podcast I can't stand going on a
podcast and everybody straight up wants
to be a gangster if shooting heroin
makes you a better guest I wanted to
shoot at
I'm not telling jokes on a popular
opinion I've never heard that before
something there's something there for
you
no there's always something there for
you on the offer you kool-aid UK quickly
yeah mr. Keeler this some club soda
there's something by what if I could
loosen you up with your loose I'm
getting yeah all right yeah is Lister to
get to is loosey-goosey is [ __ ] like
that I'm just happy that it's so weird
that I've known you for a long time ten
years at night and you've always been a
fan of comedy why just kind of it's kind
of like it's kind of like train just an
escape it's another world it's I've
always enjoyed company though I only
been into comedy for uh I mean it
probably since high school but I showed
it like when I started meeting comics
and just going to live events it was
that's when I was really more of a fan
some less goal the football lot growing
up one no yeah once in a while no no
like it is out here though being so
close but what's the closest plugged you
out
Oh should we Owen take two blocks away
which one can imagine what's closed now
but I remember what it's called it would
give his always it wasn't nothing like
nineties anything close down like mid
90s what do you have what do you live
close to now do you live close to the
Irvine improv oh yeah where I'm at now
yet airline for sure
yeah have you been to the there's a
place called the rec room near you that
could be pretty fun cuz you so do you
like it when you're doing the training
camp do you like every week or so every
couple weeks you go see do something go
see a movie just to let your mind relax
every once in a while yeah if you're
focused on that for all day every day
you're gonna lose your mind
so probably the reason you fight do I
mean do you fight not that you fight you
do Jiu Jitsu and you do
muy Thai I like
I got Friday and Saturdays I like
working out going to the world having
like a protein shake one of those ones
that you get at 7-eleven or health food
store and I like watching something on
Netflix something completely different
of what I'm gonna talk about do I just
to really get my mind off what's in
front of me the next step from there my
clothes already laid out for the night
he's just taking a shower coming out
getting dressed going over my notes one
more time and then leave it that's the
way I do it now to really try to help me
add one that's why I like sitcoms cuz
I'm not gonna pay I don't need to pay
attention to them that's why I haven't
watched Norco yet cuz it's in Spanish
and I have to really pay attention it's
uh I just turned something on and I'll
play on my computer do stuff on my phone
if I have to if I'm eating lunch but I
don't have when I grew up I love TV I
would have TV on constantly I used to
love TV now now I barely have it on I
watched like one or two episodes a day
of something just want to eating or if I
if I have ten seconds but it's uh
I love sitcoms my old sitcoms
I have to I have to watch Sanford and
Son I think that's the next one when I
start let's finish one it's great to
watch especially in the field that you
get into it's great when we watch old
television so you could see the contrast
and the change over the years camera
angles and once you start acting you
start thinking about that [ __ ] you know
to that level yet but it's good to watch
movies I'm a fan of the movie I'm a fan
of all that [ __ ] because eventually
you're gonna do one you know I'm saying
so did you think you're gonna act when
he first started comedy because right
now if you do you think you're gonna act
knows me I have no plan of that other
than to make my commercials no
I didn't know commercials is just when
they approached me at the improv I
didn't know what to adorn my like I'm
barely doing it you want the commercials
I'm like what you told a lot and they
like come meet us at the office I asked
my friends and they go yeah almost
commercials you see on TV wouldn't they
shoot I don't [ __ ] know did you go
down there so I went down the Sun bar
Thurman Arion that's a good one they
entered I heard they this is 20 years
ago they were one of the best and they
asked me if I wanted to sign and the
first commercial I went on was a
church's fried chicken commercial on
Sunset two blocks away from Fairfax
heading east of the corner I was a
commercial spot it's amazing how this
town like is set out and like it's set
up to for this but like today I wasn't
got envelopes and I was like a dollar
fifty each like Google the ones that you
put your headshot in and let it open
this open window so you can see the
headshot so it's not just regular yellow
envelope just want to send a regular
yellow they said the woman I went to the
club they don't book I'm telling you how
to book okay Alton what Stacy I got a
see that it's an envelope with your
headshot oh that they know what's in it
I want them to look at it and think they
getting divorced receipt I heard they
were never even open it that's what I
heard dog they open it okay this why the
guy already made a mistake when he told
you to mail them in oh I'm definitely
going to drop them off but because when
you mail and then it's you and 20 other
people when you're trying to get an
agent of any statute right you're trying
to do what the other guy isn't exactly
um no absolutely so if I'm getting an
envelope with your headshot already and
I know what you want it's the holidays I
don't want to look at it I want an
envelope to not be yellow I want it to
be white I wanted to stick out
everybody's dropping off with him we'll
open them another hand below I want you
ever loved to be read
I want your envelope to stick out in
that bunch this is from A to Z this is a
psychological move from A to Z
if not you're doing what everybody else
is doing and your and your your uh your
rate of success is just as high as
everybody else and failing I'm not
getting an agent there's people who will
sit here for ten years
and tell you they can't get an agent I
used to get an agent a day every day I'd
start with a call go up there drop low
personally I don't give a [ __ ] what you
tell me there's a guy by Laurel Canyon
across from Gelson's oh there's a little
building over there in that building
there's four or five little agents
there's an old man over there that in
his thing he says please no soliciting
don't drop off package
you don't need [ __ ] times I dropped
up I just knocked on that punk-asses
wall door really and he'll again and
then this house of pies and then if you
go down more there's a building there
that looks like a regular building like
doctor's office uh they cast three shows
out of there that's really I've cast a
Mentalist out of there things like a
sack after building is yeah you go in
there you go to the second floor it's
casting people you drop off your [ __ ]
headshots okay
that's the hustle in this town that
these [ __ ] don't know because
that assistant might be a podcast
listener and he's really run back there
and go guess who's here Lisa I had to
find you and the casting directors gonna
go what I mean is that you gotta see him
he's a [ __ ] he hangs out with Joe
Diaz and Kate Quigley and Jake
Ellenberger when he's not high he's
funny
no yeah somebody someone recognize me
when I got the envelopes today don't
[ __ ] with me I know how to do this from
A to Z here what hands are freakin with
the hardest company again with three
arts okay Ricky Cruz came up to me cuz
I'm gonna go mail a bunch of thing ago
don't I go if I look like you I would
not mail a thing walk in there put on
your prettiest [ __ ] and walk in there
you're not mother fault came to me three
days later and said three guards sign
them because the chick
cute at the reception desk and she was
young and Ricky was young and she went
right rabbit back then she goes you
gotta see this hot guy so you always
drop your [ __ ] off I got home looking
for jobs
well it says to mail your resume and
it's a man don't have a job you don't
have a job you might as well walk it in
and let them see your shoes how they
shine and let them see your shirt how
it's hiring and let them see your hair
that's a higher rate of getting things
that's why I'd never believed in none of
those casting workshops or anything
because they do everything the white way
when you get break down to break down so
it comes out every day and it tells you
what movies they're shooting when you
get break down it's the first thing it
says under the title and the casting
directors name is no phone calls that's
the first thing I'm gonna do because
you're not playing by the rules you're
trying to feed your [ __ ] family
yeah into a mentor I think if your
headshots look like everybody else's
headshots I'm not gonna open it takes
every [ __ ] agent every day comes
upstairs with a bucket of [ __ ]
envelopes
I'm sure absolutely they were all in
manila envelopes so what do you have to
send a pink envelope smart that's the
next one I run out of evil with beauty
not not when you run out you're not
gonna waste your time has away they're
white they're not Manila either why
would the clear front but maybe you're
right maybe but I'm gonna I'm gonna walk
it in I don't want I don't want people
seeing nope I want them to see
it's a mystery what's in there okay up
what's in you know if you wanna see if
they you got to give me a mystery why am
I gonna open up the envelope I get 50
[ __ ] envelopes a day what can I put
on it what can I write on it what can I
do to make this envelope stick out and
we're not talking about acting here
we're talking to my generalities even if
you're looking for a job I don't give a
[ __ ] if they tell you the man
then you're always gonna walk it in and
then I may be wrong you might get then
the doors blocked and there's no
receptionist you put it under the
[ __ ] door let them step on it
I don't give a [ __ ] if you're looking
for a [ __ ] job do you know how I got
my agents and managers in Hollywood I
would find out where the agencies were
that I wanted to be at and I would go to
happy hour like right when the agencies
would let out work [ __ ] taking like you
can take an envelope there but hang out
where they hang out and I would just
talk to people and get to know people
and I would never ask anyone to rep me
just slowly over time I'd mention what I
do network that's a secret and smart too
I also don't look like you but it went
that wasn't Jake Ellenberger he didn't
throw his voice I was paid quickly for
you people going [ __ ] Jake and throw his
voice but when that wait is good Jake
I'm not gonna put you through this
anguish anymore I'm gonna let you sit
down it was a bad night we're gonna have
you back next month and not let you
smoke pot no more this one hit hold I
could see you again flashbacks of
wrestling and all that [ __ ] but it was
just great seeing you I'm happy you came
out for the shows and they were violent
said hello I've always been a fan of
your inside and outside the ring me I
don't want to see you fight no more you
got a wife and a kid I don't want to see
you counting fingers in [ __ ] like that
and now so we got to figure out you show
up tell me about a line of great stuff
whether they're massage ball you once
gave me a foam roller that was vibrating
that's still used from today so the
quality was good that's probably three
years ago we met at the back of the
Denny's like a druggie he gave me that
one of their walls which my wife uses
I'm over a roll a guy what's the website
they can go and look uh hi Bryce hi
Bryce calm hyper hyper iced hyper eyes I
see yeah I summon high price tag huh
yeah do me a favor if you were any type
of what have you do whatever you doing
to get exercise
and I'd like Kate that's okay this one
here is it's a it's a hyper vault
vibration massage device and I know Kate
likes when the guy holds it himself he
could hold it with his right hand and
put his [ __ ] in your mouth with his left
hand
bro that's how you do it classy guy
knows you hold the vibrator and control
it we have secrets don't do it to their
speed
you got that machine gun vibrator hand
and then you put the cop in it but this
this is brilliant I'm shooting her in
the [ __ ] so everybody's getting turned
down taping some shoot you in the [ __ ]
I think I'm shooting during the [ __ ]
but in reality I'm beating the [ __ ] out
of a clip I'm taking them pounding it
down into the ground and pound it's like
the pizza Hut people list their fix the
sidewalks and roadways Domino's we're
doing the same thing here fix includes
high price hyper vault
this is called the hyper volts alright
it's really featuring quiet glide
technology so are the laws in hyper
vault the hyper ice yeah hi Bryce the
company yeah hi Bryce calm right
hi Bryce calm I have the hyperbole and I
believe no I really enjoy that foam
roller guys if you're a little old you
know your recoveries very hard I roll
the back of my legs I roll each side of
my back never roll on the spine he's
right there having a holiday so I'll
give you a free case and they have free
shipping over $75 right now I see Kate
vibrating and jumping up and down a for
spokesmen okay like with a construction
helmet all in goggles have me come over
and drilled with that [ __ ] thing
until something busts I'm saying dad
will be on porn ok so if you have sex
and you know what God was you're not
living
last time I had sex with a stranger I
walk goggles that was sperm everywhere
reach the eyeballs no it's not gonna hit
me like Visine I'm a soldier in that my
brother Jake I wish you and your family
a beautiful happy I was happy you came
up here was just good seeing you you're
the good guy and I appreciate that
whatever you decide to do I love you no
matter what I'm a fan of the juggernaut
Thank You Joey but uh I appreciate it
you have a family now and a wife and
children and you want to be able to
communicate with them you don't want to
sit on a couch 20 years from now swanly
spines neck there's been a flying month
and you know it's off like two weeks
guilty nothing I swear to God last week
was sitting here people were talking he
opens up his backpack and now flies a
fly that was in his backpack he's like
been member been he said mice
you know Willard you ever see the movie
Willard no you're too young for this
[ __ ] anyway I'm at the Templar arena
it's probably soul ruling company the
Templar arena and my mind is serene and
your mind it's a Brewing Company in my
mind holding a googol arena and mine
when I'm performing there for the 30,000
people you're insane I'm like merci K
before he took his dick out living large
[ __ ] I'm at the Templar arena
Wednesday night the temblor Brewing
Company and then nothing took the seven
27th to the 29th I'm at levee live in
Oxnard I hope to see all you
[ __ ] out there but my man Jake
always a pleasure
I'll inviting fellow shows also and no
more marijuana
I made a mistake with the real Jake
Ellenberger please stand up and nobody
stands up in the room ain't no Jake
Ellenberger no boy haven't seen it you
must be like my twin [ __ ] brother
yeah you have a twin brother right
Yeah right what's your name Joe Joe Joe
Joe Joe we all look nothing alike
[ __ ] if you don't look like you
you'll blame
yeah unless he's buying drinks that he's
my brother and if he's buying dinner I
love this [ __ ] guy if not I don't
know nothing anyway I love you guys I'll
see you bright and early Monday morning
December 10th ready to [ __ ] rock
[ __ ] have a great weekend I want
to thank my man Jake again I want to
thank Christ killer but most importantly
I want to thank you guys for supporting
the podcast and making this one there's
a lot you guys don't have none I'd like
to thank the beautiful cake Quigley for
showing up with a tight pants a little
[ __ ] fairies wet boots boots I like a
seat for those pants she's got a thong
on that's burning in exam the bottom of
it is nice and stiff not often it's nice
and stiff like the anyway it's crusty
like that yeah yeah I like when the moon
was crusty and misses that means he's
got character you don't say it all right
I want to thank my man Jake Ellenberger
was [ __ ] up to the gills he forgive us
tonight this weed I got a 32% it's
killing [ __ ]
I'm surprised - poor bastard walked out
of here but I love him with all my heart
he's good man
he's retired whatever he's doing he's
got our blessing come back whenever the
[ __ ] he wants I want to thank the [ __ ]
[ __ ] over here but most
importantly I want to thank you guys and
don't forget 23andme calm that's the way
to go it's the easiest Christmas present
gonna get for anybody people love that
stuff and today from today on December 6
to the 25th 23andme DNA kits are on sale
the 23andme helps you understand what
your DNA can tell you about you and your
family's story it's named for the 23
pairs of chromosomes then make up our
DNA now it's easy to do you simply spit
into it - provided in your toy tree and
make it register your sample to your
personal account and 23andme and a few
weeks you receive a personalized online
report for me it was nice and easy
I found them from the
per Spain I got people from West Africa
I'm American Indian I'm a little Chinese
and I got a little Russian Jew in me it
was all very interesting you understand
me and they show you how to stuff you
learn how your genes play a role and
your well-being your lifestyle choices
your muscle composition you sleep
movement the arms and legs twitch while
you're sleeping with 23andme sleep
movement report listen it doesn't stop
the cilantro taste aversion many people
just like cilantro describing the taste
of soapy do you have the genetic markers
associated with the aversion I mean this
is how deep 23andme
I mean it's a phenomenal service and as
a present they're gonna love it so do me
a favor from today to December 25th you
get 30% off any 23andme kit order your
23andme kit calm / Church that's your
kit right now today 30% off that's the
number 23andme dot-com / church again
that 23andme coms last year you'll be
supporting us and you began somebody
thought tremendous Christmas present
that's it it's easy get three or four of
them what are you care you give them out
like handshakes vote for me go to
23andme comm slash Church get 30% off
your DNA kit alright
number two you know what you know I told
you people I talk to you be looking hard
I'll need to said some things you don't
need to sell and that's an [ __ ]
washing cleaning a portable bidet and
that's where helped her she comes in why
have I been with them for three four
years because I love them to [ __ ]
death if it holds my asking you imagine
where does the in my skinny ass now you
want to keep it nice you want to keep
the muffler clean say I got a little
loofah I like keeping my [ __ ] clean
even though I don't go down on that
street you always want to keep your
[ __ ] clean and listen hello - she
provides that service for you with a
portable bidet
you could pick all the prices start at
$69 with a 60 day money back guarantee
which listen there is toughest [ __ ]
nails okay
what you do is you say it takes 15
minutes to the store you don't need a
plumber I could do it leakage do at
least really taught me how to do it over
can phone you could even get hot water
settings Mita can you imagine reading
the paper with lukewarm water it yeah so
what the [ __ ] are you going where the
[ __ ] are you going go - hello - she calm
take a look at what they got again
another Christmas present that easy
they started $69 you show up with that
for grandpa who's gonna who's gonna
leave you more money at the will nobody
takes care like uncle Joey go - hello -
she calm again I want to thank all the
guests this week who was it
Jake and my man who was Monday somebody
Oh [ __ ] Rikki Rockett
and crema nice nice guy listen to both
podcasts I want to thank them I'm gonna
thank 23andme I want to thank [ __ ]
quip I want to thank tushy I want to
thank the Fuji Sports calm anybody was
in our corner you know we got you - but
most importantly I want to thank you
guys that listen cuz your family will
the church family here so do me a favor
enjoy your weekend and we'll be back
Monday morning tip-top Magoo ready to
rock all right don't forget October 27th
to the 29th I'm at levity live December
I'm at levee live up there in Oxnard
California if you're not doing nothing
up to Christmas come on up let's smoke a
[ __ ] number and have a good time all
right beside that I'll see you this
weekend I thought Hawaii a comedy store
if not I'll see you next Wednesday at
the temblor up there in beautiful
[ __ ] Bakersfield
have a great weekend be safe uncle Joey
loves you stay black check this [ __ ]
meal leaf